normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is big news it's breaking uh just a few
couple hours ago Harvard covered up a
secret plagiarism probe into president
Claudine gay during anti-Semitism storm
threatened the post so this is uh uh
ongoing yeah while this whole Scandal
like before this uh this stuff's going
on before at least to finic questions
sir apparently she was investigated for
plagiarism we have this huge thread from
Aaron sarum who says Chris rufo's
examples are just the tip of the iceberg
in four articles published between 93
and 2017 including her
dissertation gay paraphrased or quoted
almost 20 authors without proper
attribution in some cases lifting entire
paragraph's verbatim he's got the
evidence right here her disseration
began it was the best of times it was
the worst of times I mean look look look
this is a massive Scandal where we are
learning that the president of Harvard
plagiarized her way into through her
dissertation for for for over 20 years
they know this they knew this they
covered it up she then makes shockingly
offensive statements and they refuse to
fire her New York Post reports it's
great to be a leftist yeah that's right
you can do nothing you can do no wrong
Hunter Biden look at that Harvard
University covered up a highlevel
investigation into whether its
controversial president was a plagiarist
and used an expensive Law Firm to
threatened the post over our own probe
the college announced Tuesday morning
that it investigated Claud Dean gay over
whether some of her academic work was
plagiarized and had cleared her of
breaching the college's standards for
research misconduct I will say it again
the only qualification for the job is
that you are a member of the cult and
then everything else is irrelevant she
is a good cult member she serves the
cult should we fire of course not she's
doing her job yeah all that matters is
pushing is pushing the ideology all that
matters is pushing leftist and that's
when that's what I was trying to talk
about with like the NAACP calling for
the boycott of of of of florid state in
America all these institutions all they
do is push leftist ideas and when they
come into clash with reality if reality
is is not the leftist agenda then
reality gets pushed aside but even if
they fire her even if they fire her
they're just going to replace her with
someone just as bad the same kind of
cult member that's going to be giving
out that woke Kool-Aid the same kind of
individual that's going to be along the
same lines so I don't I don't understand
why they won't fire her and just replace
her with a worse person and then kind of
appease the mob that's trying to she's
good at what she does as a as a priest
of wokeness the sad thing is is that as
we're having this conversation there is
still a lovely patriotic quote unquote
patriotic no I won't even quote unquote
patriotic American family that is
sitting there with their 17-year-old
daughter and they are plotting to get
her into Harvard they waiting for that
letter being like fingers crossed and
they're doing all the essays and they
they hear about this but they're like
but we have to get our daughter Preston
Prescott bookcase whatever her name is
we have to get her into Harvard or Yale
or Princeton or wherever so this is it
right now that has to stop everyone
needs to refuse to work with people who
have degrees from Harvard MIT and upen
uh until they they they back down and
the institutions are are are recaptured
and deified I don't even think you know
Porto was like until they fired these
individuals I'm like you got to root out
the corruption you've got to you got to
grab the the weed and pull it out by the
roots and so my my attitude is you you
you you want to apply to job here just
don't put it on your resume yeah and and
it has to get to the point that anyone
over a certain age Maybe Harvard 20
years ago was different who knows maybe
it was exactly the same but at a certain
age now if you meet someone under 30 who
is very proud and they brag that they
went to Harvard their response has to be
just pure laughter it's like when your
friends's like I'm I'm a huge Browns fan
and you're like you're a Browns fan like
no offense to Browns fan fans of course
as a Giants fan um right but it has to
get it has to you know get that gut
reaction of just laughter like oh you
went to Harvard oh my God please what
you learn how to point out the different
races in the room exact I'm looking for
a guy who knows how to like I don't know
design a building not how to criticize
People based on their race next next
next to a candidate get out of my face
yeah that and I love the way that you
that Dave P is doing that and others are
saying that that's the best way to solve
these problems is when the schools
become unmarketable because of the
product they create and and that's that
is our own fault culturally as an as a
nation we have elevated these schools to
well I mean he did go to when all this
stuff started you had these Wall Street
investors vowing to not hire any of
these people instantly the students who
fil who signed this document praising
Hamas backtracked and apologized and
they're like oh gez oh no and it's like
no I'll take their apology thank you now
now now the the institution like don't
stand behind this stuff yeah except that
if you go down this path you lose but
you know the issue was there was who was
it some guy said don't hold it against
these students they didn't even know
what they signed I'm like oh now I'm
really going to hold it against them you
signed something without reading it wow
you are really dumb yeah I'm not going
to hire you the plagiar isn't thing just
is is just further evidence of how
corrupt these organizations are but our
own president plagiarized his thesis he
had a drop out of the presidential
election in 1980 or ' 84 because of it
he took JFK speeches and and now
and literally said them as if they were
his and this was back in the back in the
day where of course you could fact check
everything right away immediately but
then news organizations literally took
speeches of former presidents and then
put it by Biden saying the same exact
thing that's how much of a phony that's
how much of a fake he is and that's how
the entire institution is set up it's
propped up all on a bed of lies and
that's why they're so afraid of the
truth coming out that's why they're so
afraid of Independent Media and this is
why I think this moment is is so
captivating right now because it
wouldn't have happened if it wasn't for
individuals being able to organize and
talk to each other on social media and
this is now where their institutions
that they controlled before are totally
being called out are totally being
liquidated or totally imploding I love
it it's beautiful I love seeing all of
it happen unfold right in front of me
and let's go MIT we need we need more
controversy there immediately lots of
very high intelligence figures coming
from that institution as well that do
some really really shady stuff
especially when it comes to pushing a
lot of scops and cultural uh Warfare on
the American people and a lot of it
being appropriated right now in Congress
as they're talking about reauthorization
of of of uh fisa courts the surveillance
courts spying on American CI right now
is in real time MIT is essentially the
playground of the Intel agencies and
they're able to do a lot of really crazy
stuff and then this is not the only
controversy that we have with these
prestigious institutions there's more
here folks there's Epstein who had an
office at Harvard who literally was able
to have office hours and have a cozy
relationship with all the young students
most of them some of them prebent
students that he had access to har at
Harvard you prebent students at Harvard
dude I don't know there's a lot of
children that are also introduced that
are like Scholars and super smart as
well maybe like daycares or something
hey that man he's around 18year olds
that that should be questionable
especially with Harvard giving him a
essentially his own office why did
Jeffrey Epstein have his own office at
har that should be the big issue that
should be the big controversy here not
that she plagiarized everything let's
get into the deep roots of how all these
horrible institutions are doing some
really awful things on another level
that we don't even know about yet you
think EP was woke I think that's a good
question no I think he was beyond woke I
think he was just evil incarnate I don't
even think he woke has an agenda and an
ideology that is trying to promote he is
just the devil but but I'm sure he was
the kind of guy was like yeah sure
whatever was a leftist yeah but but he
did wasn't trying to push an agenda he
he was he was just just the devil the I
think that the one thing that we really
are kind of glossing over is the fact
that these institutions this isn't new
and these institutions have been pushing
people out o like every year after year
after year after year there are college
graduates going
into society that believe this stuff
right they if they minor in this stuff
they they they go into society and they
believe this stuff they affect society
we have a crisis of Competency coming in
the United States and possibly in the
broader West and there are things that
like if we lose the knowledge of how to
do them then we're going to have serious
problems like it there's a whole complex
world out there that needs to be
maintained and if we're if we're dumping
out people that can't think that aren't
aren't coming out of the the highest you
know supposed ly the highest uh uh
universities that we have um if they
can't think and they're not actually
able to do the jobs that they're put
into these jobs have real world
consequences I mean we there's the first
thing that comes to my mind frequently
is is the fact that they're having
problems filling the air traffic
controllers uh I don't think that you
have to go to Harvard to be an air
traffic controller but you have to be
smart and you have to be quick witted
and you have to be able to do the job
and you hear stories about you know oh
there's this a that almost happened or
you know this this bad call or whatever
planes had to be waved off or whatever
because of an error those kind of things
are going to com compound as we have
more and more people being put into the
labor market doing jobs that they're not
qualified for yeah or and being hired
only because of specific reasons of the
way that they were born when they're not
qualified for it as of course the number
of these traffic incidences especially
Airlines has been going up dramatically
as I'm now walking into the cockpit
looking who who's my pilot compounding
that also is not just that they are are
poorly educated compounding is that they
think they are very well educated
because they went to Harvard and I'm
sure they will tell you like look I just
took a semester last last semester I
took a course on the you know Taylor
Swift's latest album I mean that is an
actual course and you want to say like
how how will that help you at all in
life I'm sure it's cool if you like
Taylor Swift but what the hell does that
help you accomplish in life but but they
graduate thinking they are very
it's all part of the degrowth agenda
they want to reduce population they want
to reduce development and if you take a
person you put them in a
institutionalized learning facility for
24 years and you have them major in
folklore mythology I mean at least
that's more valuable than Taylor Swift
no no offense I mean you can like Taylor
Swift but studying that yeah there's a
lot of useless majors and then you
graduate and you go I can't get a job
now what does that result in your
failure why are young people you go to
Occupy Wall Street young people are not
having kids and they often say it's
because they can't afford it that's
necessarily the reason because most
people can never afford it you got to
figure it out but a lot of these kids
are saddled to debt they can't pay rent
and it's because their degrees are
nonsensical yeah they have no real world
skills to trade value yeah and there has
to be you hear so much about the the
growing mental health problem of young
people that has to contribute to a lot
of mental health if you are the best
intentioned college graduate from
Harvard and you did study human ecology
and Taylor Swift and diversity and all
that crap but you're still a nice
22-year-old girl and then you graduate
and you have a useless degree with no
skill set no wonder why you have mental
health problems because you can't hold
down a job you aren't qualified for any
job you think you have this incredibly
valuable Harvard degree you have
$300,000 worth of debt of of course that
will lead to drug addiction problems
sexual addiction problems gender
confusion problems because how miserable
are you if you have gotten to this point
where you're supposed to be entering
into the world of adulthood and you're
actually just proven to be an even
greater child than when you started the
entire process and now you're indebted
and essentially a debt slave to the big
banksters that of course you're going to
have to now pay off with a horrible
corporate job that you don't want to be
working in that you're going to end up
for the rest of your life until you
retire and then quickly die afterwards a
you ask Jo Biden to re absolve your debt
you go to Occupy Wall Street like you
saw 12 years ago and you lay down in Pro
test you you do something but then
eventually you cease to exist yeah you
have no kids you have no family you have
no skills you're placed in a home
clock's ticking and these these people
in these polyes they're going to be 50
60 years old they're not going to have
any kids and they're going to be like I
need someone to work to to bring food to
me and they're going to be like screw
off yeah when we're watching this trend
where gen Z is becoming more
conservative or I should say jenz is
more conservative in many ways and in
some some degrees they're becoming more
conservative you think Jen Alpha and the
Next Generation after that are going to
want to spend their tax dollars to fund
a bunch of woke leftist commies who
don't want to work yeah it's already bad
enough where we've had this issue I
remember when I was a kid they said
you're being text young Tim pool to pay
the Social Security of an older
generation and the way the system works
is if you've got one if you've got a
hundred old people on Social Security
you need 200 young people to all give a
portion of their revenue to fund the
lives of the old people the argument
being once you're old you'll have 400
young people to fund your life and so on
and so forth it's impossible so what's
going to happen when they do this
degrowth when population is retracting
and you're going to have a bunch of woke
Millennials in their 60s being like
where's my Social Security and there's
going to be some 25-year-old be like you
ain't taking my money no and then
there's only going to be there's going
to be 100 Millennials and there's going
to be 50 of the younger generation and
they're going to be like I ain't working
for you and that's inevitable cuz Social
Security is insolvent I think 2035 is
the year that it's already in in in
solvent if you're under the age of 30
that should be your primary issue
greater than anything else going on in
your life it should be the fact that you
are paying into a system that is going
to go insolvent and you will not see a
dime of that money so you are paying for
yeah some some some liberal you know
agent hippie thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net